[Music]
former wonder year star Fred Savage is
facing new allegations and today his
accuser took legal action the
allegations of assault battery
harassment and discrimination were filed
in a lawsuit today by Y J Wong a former
costume designer from the 2015 Fox
comedy the grinder crying I was a pain I
was humiliated and no it's good
in a statement to eat t savage calls the
allegations quote completely without
merit and absolutely untrue Fox also
tells et quote we conducted a thorough
investigation into these allegations and
found no evidence of any wrongdoing on
the part of mr. savage in 2015 he was on
the set of the grinder during our
interview Savage was upbeat he even
wanted to keep the interview going
longer
despite being needed back on set this is
the second allegation of negative onset
behavior to surface against savage at
this year in January Alli Mills who
played Fred's mom in The Wonder Years
claimed the series came to an end in
1993 due to a sexual harassment suit
filed against him by a wardrobe stylist
Savage denied those allegations but
ridiculous sexual harassment suit that
was going on it was so not true Fred was
only 11 years old when et first
interviewed him at home in Chicago
my head starts getting bigger it's over
hard it's really bad
[Music]